American Gary brown and friends set out
for a day of sightseeing gary is here to
help build a new US Embassy in the
war-torn nation until 2001 Sierra Leone
had been ravaged by a decade of bloody
civil war
but today is tranquil and gary looks
forward to spending his day off some new
friends from Freetown it's a beautiful
day verb or just laughed and cutting up
we were all happy driver ISA Kanu knows
just the place to show his visitors
several miles outside the capital city
he steers them along an isolated
mountain road
then without warning what's going on
what is that man
Olson is this big black Perry
I thought gorilla
really didn't know what it was at first
you know what was so quick
the Americans delight and seemed the
great aid but Issa has a very different
reaction
Adisa knew something no we didn't know
and he slammed the car makers suddenly
the animal charges
the car hurtles backward
what the ape keeps on
could believe what I'm singing close
where he got to the car picker he was he
just looking at you like this and he's
angry look and he's screaming
Gary Brown and his friends faced the
onslaught of an enraged and dangerous
primate but there are no gorillas in
Sierra Leone the powerful animal
attacking the car is a chimpanzee